Joshua how are you I'm very good
Brittany how are you I'm well thank you
listen congrats on this series
um
thrilling good good
uh listen I want to jump right into it
let's do it it's so cool that this is a
television show now and I feel like
we're getting to see a lot more of you
know the damage that you know Dan
creates
um and like what what part of this
character did you find the most
interesting
well you know it's it was being able to
jump into that right so that the movie
is Iconic and it's actually still a
great movie but it definitely has a
perspective of its own time right and
the opportunity to tell this story where
you really examine
the like this guy's in why is he so
incapable of taking responsibility for
his own actions and then when he's
his own actions what is the additional
damage that he causes out of that Pride
that vanity whatever it is right and you
see it it's not just him that he crushes
he crushes his wife his child his work
relationships his best friendship and
you know pride is a killer right it will
really it can drive you to some ugly
ugly places and our story allows us the
opportunity to not just examine it in
the moment right when his ego reaches
out and has an affair reaches out to
this woman who's not his wife to like
flatter himself but also we flash into
the future and now you see long after
the event is over what his pride has
actually cost everybody and I thought it
was really interesting to be able to
tell the the story after the story
normally ends right right right yeah
absolutely
um all right so you were in the movie
the safety of objects with Glenn back in
yeah hey what what Toronto uh did you
ever you know have the opportunity to
talk to her about this project
randomly so I had like only bump into
her in random places and it only happens
every couple of years and randomly just
before we started this I bumped into her
last year and so I told her like hey you
know we're gonna remake this thing what
do you think and
you know she has an interesting
relationship with with that movie
because it is it's such an iconic
character so that's both the positive
and a negative over the years but it
definitely was one of the things that
launched her in her career that turned
her into Glenn Close and at the same
time she had a much she had a very
different version of who Alex Forest is
right and she didn't she feel like she I
think I don't want to put words in her
mouth but my impression is that she
feels that they turned her into a crazy
lady right
and I think that has always bugged her
that it is not a like nobody's just a
crazy person they're a person and they
have all other kinds of things going on
but you're a person and so I told her I
was like look the the one of our main
focuses here is that we have the
opportunity because we have time right
it's a TV format rather than a film
format so we're going to take this
opportunity to really get into who this
woman is like where she comes from why
she is the way she is and then we're
also going to use that time to make him
maybe a little bit culpable for his own
actions because you know that power
dynamic in the film is from a modern
perspective off right like he skates and
she's cut holding the bag he's the
victim and she's the crazy lady and you
know we're not there anymore thank God
right right amazing what's really cool
that you were able to get her
perspective because as you said iconic
character which sometimes you're like
will it live up to this but it's it's a
beautiful you know it's a it's a very
interesting take on it and again and I
love that you use the opportunity to uh
to really like dive in deep
um what else are you gonna do right yeah
exactly has Jody had the opportunity to
see any of this
no she hasn't there Paramount plus is
very very like secure with their links
so the I don't know how when they send
them to you but like the signing process
is not easy right definitely don't want
you sharing things before they want you
sharing things so I am the only person
in my family who has seen this show so
far okay okay all right well I'm excited
for when she does see it yeah I'm very
excited uh so I wanted to also talk
about your daughter who is turning three
in April yeah
um I have a 14 month old and I'm just
like wondering how were the terrible
twos congratulations so terrible twos
um boy or girl can I ask oh girl yeah
congratulations
is she walking
she is she's running Joshua she's
running 14 months you are in for it
um well I will tell you that it really
all the cliches are true it really does
get better you are really going to mourn
every little baby every day because
every day it's a new baby and you're
gonna miss that baby but you're gonna be
so excited to meet this baby
um and the
here's my take on the terrible twos
they're not actually terrible
it's just that she's every single
version of herself she will ever be in
30 minutes oh my gosh okay that's
overwhelming yeah she's like all the
pieces of you can I just watch it on her
face she's just like the swirl and he
takes it you gotta keep up but it's like
eventually it locks in and you're like
okay this we can deal with it yeah yeah
everything else is noise noise noise and
then we get to like this is where you
actually are living right now but it is
magical enjoy every single second of it
oh thank you so much well you too I'm
I'm thrilled three feels like a very
it's a big birthday I feel like it's and
I you know who's the most excited about
it the third birthday
she started singing herself happy
birthday the other day at the kitchen
table she is very prepared to turn three
I love that I love that I'm sure we've
got a theme we've got all the things we
want yeah Daddy's a bit you should have
seen our Christmas tree this year it was
obnoxious was it you got to go big you
got to go big or go way over the top
this year
amazing well thank you so much Joshua
it's been wonderful to speak with you
and I'm really excited for the world to
see this thank you yeah me too